in any case here already right we're
going to assume that C is so hello and
welcome to the new world review which
sounds weird say today we are going to
have a bit of an informal discussion
about the Broly movie featuring a
star-studded cast so let's all go around
the table and introduce ourselves and
how we relate to Dragon Ball Z starting
with droid hello my name is droid and I
have been watching Dragon Ball since I
was like 5 and I love it it's become a
part of my life and that's it fantastic
cheese introduce yourself hi I'm Keith
and I like Dragon Ball I watched it when
I was a kid just a few episodes here and
there and then I met destroyed guy and
became in love with it traitor Dragon
Ball both both fair enough Homa
introduce yourself please
hi I'm Homer Gunn - Dragon Ball probably
when I was around like 12 and just like
watch the [ __ ] out of it sir yeah solid
tactical Groot please introduce yourself
sir I am Groot I've been in the Dragon
Ball community for around the past five
years and everything Dragon Ball GT fair
enough
and finally my name is Liam I usually
make one-piece video so this is very
very weird for me I am an old man and I
was watching Dragon Ball when I was 11 I
think and I am much older than that now
yeah so we have pretty similar
experiences jack yeah I think we have a
very similar experience just on other
sides of the world all right so let's
begin feel free to jump in whenever you
have a thought what did you think guys
amazing personally I love the fact that
they went and changed some of the
history and gave us a more concrete
background story for Frieza and the
Saiyans instead of just you know
Bardock could see the future then goku
got sent to earth to destroy it and you
know now i don't know it kind of changes
the whole dynamic of the background
story if you think about it goku is
never sent to earth to destroy it now
which I kind of like but yeah yeah it's
really interesting I'm not sure how I
feel about it I quite like it so devotes
an it retelling of it just yet it messes
with everything I've known for close to
two decades which isn't a bad thing it's
always nice to keep things fresh yeah I
think the only thing
I'm not really that keen on was the
demet butter a little bit too soft my
opinion too softer saying warrior yes
yeah because usually it's been like oh
yeah science they don't really care
about that family like that yeah and
then there was these hugging his wife so
and and asking about Goku and rabbits
and yeah yeah before this we
legitimately thought that he never even
met Goku or rat it's the Goku is in a
pod in his house now so which means more
sense for lower-class warrior yeah and
his mother was just there doing the
cooking yes like Kiki yeah it is very
kind oh cheese you misogynist
it all comes yeah fact that the story of
Dragon Ball pretty much was made up as
it went along for example the whole
alien thing and Frieza and the planet
I'm kind of glad that they did go back
and give us like a concrete this is what
happened because like I said they always
kind of just threw Frieza on us we never
knew what Frieza was doing all these
years ago while Goku was on earth you
know what I mean but now we got the
whole King cult left the Empire - Frieza
and this and that it was pretty cool I
liked it yeah I loved the introduction
scene with King Cole passing the torch
to freezer even more of a dick than I am
yeah I know I love how he just is like
oh people have weapons trained on us in
these buildings well die die die
something concrete a concrete background
to like it so instead of like yeah every
stop for Dragon Ball in a sense like
giving sort of a more concrete
background to the Saiyans and their
origins everything's like which is good
does essentially like reboot the way we
see the entire universe going forward
yeah yeah which is good because it means
I'm gonna plan for everything going
forward unless it's classic Toriyama and
he'll just sort of make up [ __ ] as he
goes I don't know the big thing that I
guess I noticed was just the fact that
like I said does that mean that Goku
never hit his head or anything like that
when he came to earth does that mean
that you know what I mean yeah and
because he's significantly older when he
was sent there doesn't mean that he's oh
like aware of his heritage now ya know
it's all kind of weird to me but like
said I don't necessarily not like it but
I still have questions like when you
think about it the very beginning of
Dragon Ball Z is irrelevant now because
Raddatz came to the planet to find out
if Goku destroyed it if you think about
it rather student really know about if
his brother was sent off to her like
take over a planet on them yeah he
probably wouldn't assume a descent yeah
by the way young Raddatz one of the
highlights of the movie for me yeah it's
just such a scrawny dick nappa had is a
luscious head of hair yeah question is
what happened to those two random
Saiyans wealth right two or three who
with with them with the planet I'm gonna
assume they got there the beats
treatment I'd assume that nappa eats all
the Saiyans that go missing that's true
he's gaining his power for his
resurrection all right sir
how did you all like the idea of broli
fitting into this official history now
kind of shoehorning in the Burley story
I thought it was done exceptionally well
surprisingly well yeah I wasn't
expecting it to be done that well at all
I agree and plus they fixed his
backstory as well yeah I mean you can
always do better when than the other
parolee movies somebody specs me instead
of daggers so I may properly stab this
baby it's also good cuz now it's not
just broglie's like ah I hate dirty ah
uh actually gives him like a raisin
twice fighting has a real relationship
to goku at all anyways you know cuz he
was sort of just told ya it's mainly
just Vegeta it's all about Vegeta it's
always all about hey you're strong I
don't know to be perfectly honest with
you though I really liked the new Broly
I liked everything about him I liked the
whole para guess saying I thought new
para guess was cooler than old para
guess definitely and yeah basically -
they just like I don't know when I was
watching it I just couldn't get the
abridged scene out of my head where um
Vegeta is talking to pay I guess and
he's like wait why does he hate Kakarot
he's like cuz he cried a lot for like
I'd try to kill him me and I think they
took note of that about like the movie I
kept honking like a bridge fights like
oh it's not purpose just don't like
seeing certain scenes like with the
bridge that's how I look at all of
Dragon Ball now yeah
very problematic actually it is even
when I play the video games I'm like oh
wow this is like Dragon Ball a bridge
cell I like him better every time I see
verge of jump in are distinct for Jason
our budget a yes no no right before this
devolves into a just track and bulls-eye
a bridge discussion one of the things I
really liked about this film was that it
was so very different in the first half
an hour to any Dragon Ball Z movie I can
recall it was just like solid story
story story there was stuff happening
and there was like no fighting it was
weird but it was really good
oh absolutely honestly after the
beginning and all the introductions I
was kind of like I don't know how this
can live up to it when the fighting
starts but realistically I was not
disappointed whatsoever when the
fighting did start like when Vegeta
through that first kick and I saw the
animation I was like wow this is gonna
be intense mmm do animation was so good
I honestly love like the so like right
after the flashback and I just loved how
to use each other each other song yeah
yeah Chella
remix I remember before Liam actually
even went and saw this movie I said that
people could actually probably watch
this movie first if they wanted to get
into Dragon Ball and I still stand by
that definitely yeah because the main
characters pretty much you do and it
doesn't feature any of the extended
costume except a piccolo it's sort of
but it kind of doesn't matter let's say
with pickles but it's hilarious that was
like I'm just trying to stand here on a
goddamn Mountain and you goddamn Saiyans
keep bringing this [ __ ] to me what I did
like is it they had a nice valid reason
for people not showing up that they
literally stated it was like look even
if I went let's be real I'd just be in
the way yeah pretty much
also rest and peace Gohan yeah
had both screen time that door there go
hannes this kind of they're in there
he's not gonna be involved in your
Hasenpfeffer as long as I can remember
honestly during the whole fighting scene
though it was almost like it could have
been a silent film almost because it was
so beautiful to watch like I didn't
really care about going back and forth
it was just awesome to watch
and then goku for some reason decided to
try to settle down Broly and just made
him more pissed which was pretty fun
freezes acting some point as well yeah
you guys all saw this in a cinema didn't
you yes anymore
yeah did you all see it in Japanese no
no I saw it in English oh my [ __ ] am I
the only one who saw it in Japanese
yep seems like it I couldn't see it join
the Japanese King Vegeta was was voiced
by Christopher sabot so it just sounded
like an older Vegeta all right so I
think we have very different experiences
of that then but the voice acting was
still one point especially for freezer
he's such an evil dick in Japanese I
love Frieza but I'm so glad that they
didn't turn him into the goddamn
antihero again yeah I was very concerned
about that I mean he did exactly what I
think everyone would have expected oh
I'm back to life right galactic
domination again wears like a scooby-doo
villain although I do love that they
went with the more comical take on him
it's like he wasn't gathering dragons to
become immortal or anything else
honestly I was glad to hear for Frieza
that he wasn't trying to wish for
immortality anymore I was like come on
Frieza you got your ass kicked it off
start working on something else
yeah and it's something that every other
villain has done almost villains have
done if they've got the Dragon Balls
inside now I have a theory do you think
that Ballmer really has been collecting
the Dragon Balls and reversing her age
five years forever oh definitely I
literally laughed when Goku is like oh
so that's how you've been doing it yeah
it's official Kenan oh yeah why when you
pay a [ __ ] too chichi did anybody else
notice the fact that we actually fought
in this movie yeah he he dodged yes you
seem to be having a good time with it
yeah it's because him and beerus usually
don't get involved but the fact that we
see was even trying to dodge it and
playing around with him was weird to me
yeah
is buying time sort of no time for good
you know first I'm really interested to
see where this relationship with Wiese
and beerus and goku go in the future
because i don't know beerus really does
seem to like the Saiyans but he's just
that [ __ ] that can't admit it there
was hurting me too it's like it's it's
really funny like the interactions I
have with my camera like when Bulma
ships off was a bullet to beerus calls
him uncle bearskins Imbler and then he's
just pretty baby sitting there yeah yeah
it's funny how at the end of the movie
he's just sitting there he's like well I
guess they did it right innit moment up
the whole movie has to be the go to
stops tell Fuji to suck what was that
mr. green I think you just stroked out
yeah my favorite part of the movie was
well calling Goku an idiot the whole
time yeah yeah it is dropped off bro
Leone Frieza
really Calphalon Frieza and just laughs
okay so when Broly hit freeze it for the
first time did anyone else as cinema
absolutely erupt into applause because
minded no I cried those losses yeah I
was laughing and cheering it was crisp
that whole say Chris is great
there was no round of applause like yeh
Broly but yeah everybody was like hahaha
freeze it was less yeah bro lee and more
ha suck it Frieza yeah which is funny
because I absolutely loved Frieza but
it's still fun to see him get points
that's the kind of character he is I
love him but I want to see him get hurt
it's get screwed over the most comical
way possible huh it's probably dumped on
top of him I can't tell you how like
disappointed slash hilarious I thought
it was when he was like having the guy
guess what his wish was and the other
one was like he wants to grow 5
centimeters and then they're like oh no
no no and he was like yes you're right
and I was like really 5 centimeters I
kind of enjoyed it cuz phrases that kind
of cool character now I did enjoy it but
I was like waiting I thought he had like
some grand plan or something but no he
just wanted to be a little bit taller it
let us know that this movie like was not
going to be a struggle for the Dragon
Balls
like this is where the whole Dragon Ball
thing
snow and it's they're not being used for
anything particularly important
yeah pretty we're just very good you're
like how Frieza states how he actually
kind of likes but I heard like part of
that what you say Frieza states you like
yeah you keep jumping out like halfway
like having that like he actually says
how he likes fighting yes he does say
that because it would make it unfair
essentially yeah he's he's becoming very
saying like in his old age he really is
which I think will eventually be his
downfall
like it was cells but like well Frieza
ever really die surreal question yeah we
thought he was dead for so long I mean
he's either gonna die or become the god
of destruction
it seemed iike he ever gets the chance
he's going to kill him as soon as he can
Vegeta is so pissed that he's still
alive it's kind of weird that they just
let Frieza go and do his own thing
because at the end of the movie where
we've got the whole happy ending with
Broly freeze is just off conquering
another planet and committing genocide
again and everyone's like ho well all's
well that ends well that's another one
of those things that remind me of Dragon
Ball abridged when he's like you won't
be destroying any more planets today
except you know that one hmm the Kogi's
let him do whatever he wants it kind of
goes off destroy the planet the time
unleashed on the universe just so that
they can fight him is it's astounding
like Goku is such a [ __ ]
yeah it's literally just like oh yeah
let Frieza go and then comes back later
beerus is the one that was just like
okay back to life you go now go kill
stuff comes the god of destruction you
know that's that's this thing that goku
is sort of like a symbol of facies a
hero in quotation marks you could just
instead of transmission to freezer kill
him and save millions potentially
billions of lives why would you save a
planet that isn't gum ik Oh exactly but
another thing I wanted to talk about was
the fact that they kind of changed Koji
t'as personality and I really liked this
new Gogeta but hmm you noticed
goku is ready to wipeout Broly like and
that was the first time we've ever seen
goku actually like I'm gonna kill this
guy
and then he vanished it went uh you know
whatever planet he was on before when
they used the Dragon Balls so it's I
don't know it's weird when goku and
vegeta combine it
like that part that Goku has that's like
no I'm gonna let this guy live so I can
fight him later is almost gone almost
yeah he has a more Vegeta like influence
like no we're taking care of this now
exactly like I was kind of surprised
that he was going for it he was like
alright I'm gonna kill him right now and
then he vanished and he was like wait
where did he go
Indian they seemed like smiling almost
sort of like he's kind of kind of just
like happy that he didn't end up doing
it happy that he's gonna fight someone
in the future
pretty much he's got a another sort of
trading partner that he could use yeah
it's funny if you also noticed early and
Dragon Ball super we stayed the comment
about how Vegeta and Goku could be
anybody if they actually worked together
and he commented on how they finally did
so in this movie which I thought was
something that was going to happen
during the tournament of power but
they're still too stubborn mmm yeah it
did seem like something that was going
to happen during actual super but I mean
it would have been fun if they would
have used the determine of how and just
failed and lost the tournament because
they failed using it's been fat go Jada
yes
versus Jaron yeah
Oh universes now I want to see ultra
instinct fat cookie eater actually happy
that he'd been in deep use in the middle
of the fight hmm well makes sense
because actually explained before it
happened oh yeah we've got 30 minutes to
do this no we've on whew suddenly yeah
and then they wasted time thinking about
a name though which made me think of
[ __ ] they are going to one for use
because they've spent all this time
trying to come up with the name that's
exactly what I was thinking but at the
same time I was like they can't do that
again they've already done the unfused
thing in the middle of a fight like what
20 times
that's how Fusion has to go there
because it's usually so powerful though
it's like alright the villain has no
chance now but they got around it in
this movie and that was done really well
well I mean because of the fact that I
think that Goku and Vegeta finally
managed to work together like and just
get it done they were like okay we've
been training and get together long
enough we're putting everything into
this even with Vegeta they're pretty
hesitant but this time they were both
finally like alright we need to do this
I also was quite happy that it didn't
that they didn't pull the ultra instinct
card and just made the fight less
exciting at the end because yeah when
you're going blue we see it's like a
second
yeah joyed you said you had a theory
about why that is I was kind of confused
when I saw that in the Cinemax Goku is
like going through his forms then I
swear I saw ultra instincts but then he
landed on blue and I was like I think
it's because Goku doesn't really have
full control over Ultra instincts so
maybe he has sir and he's borrowed
certain parts of it similar to how Luffy
you know borrowed the shave technique
but I don't think he's completely
mastered it so I think it's kind of like
a part of him like when he turned into
Super Saiyan God for the first time he's
always gonna be able to achieve that
level but it's not something he can pull
out when he needs to yet he's a weak
Super Saiyan God all this useless but I
mean isn't every form that isn't blue
kind of useless cuz it's like a member
in battle of gods doesn't he just like
when he Super Saiyan each is powerful is
using God fool well apparently when he's
red or when they're red that's like
their base form it becomes like they're
new you know black form and then when
they turn blue that's the equivalent to
Super Saiyan the only difference is
apparently red is extremely powerful but
pumps out energy way too quick but blue
can keep all the energy contained which
is why Goku can use kaio-ken again so
yeah it's a bunch of [ __ ] speaking
of Super Saiyan God Vegeta how I like it
there's how dude I have done so much
research the only way that you can turn
red they say everywhere is to do the
[ __ ] sorry let's just turn into a non
family-friendly interview but ami but I
already said the work we've made that
ships a long time every source states
that you need to have five other Saiyans
with a righteous heart blah blah blah
and we never saw that happen so and we
never see I couldn't find anywhere that
said that Vegeta completely skipped that
phase and also one last thing in the
manga he actually went red against
Frieza during the resurrection of F saga
so as in he just knew how to do it and
when
cool that was his origin I don't know
they never explained it you know what I
mean it was just kind of like how they
never really explained blue it just
showed up during the freeze of fight and
it's such a classic Vegeta thing to do
rock up with this transformation that
he's a quiet off-screen that's what I
mean like the only thing is like when I
was reading everywhere I couldn't find
anywhere that said that that he could
become one any other way besides doing
that ritual they did in battle of the
gods but when would he have time to do
that was he like all right everybody get
over here we're all holding hands and
doing this [ __ ] I want to be a god given
how he didn't want to do the fusion
dance I find that very unlikely
absolutely
maybe it's the GT syndrome bob was just
like built a new machine and he can just
like use the machine to turn into
something it won't be like that but it
might be like I mentioned GT please I a
Super Saiyan 4 is pretty cool Broly kind
of went into a Super Saiyan 4 type state
he did actually Frieza legitimate I mean
I'm
paratis legitimately breaks it down like
he has strength of a great ape and
everything like that except he's still
in his human body so that was
legitimately what the premise of Super
Saiyan 4 was and then Vegeta I mean then
freeze it decides that said enough and
he was like hey well maybe we can make
him stronger hey pay I guess [ __ ] off
and then kills him that was the funniest
thing like Broly look what's happened oh
no I know at that point I still couldn't
believe that Brawley was so loyal to his
dad even in that bazooka state but you
know it was that moment where I realized
just how much I loved Frieza he murdered
someone in front of my eyes and I loved
it I know and he didn't even flinch he
was just like huh I have an idea how
about you eat a dick and die yeah but
that's always what we've loved about
freezing even in super remember he
[ __ ] knocked his guys out of the
spaceship just for the hell of it so it
was Karma for Paris and also shot baits
in the chest goddamn they did be dirty
yeah actually no that's good he deserved
exactly what he got then
yeah Paris was such a dick at first I
didn't really realize it until he was
around the rest of the freeze of forests
and he was you know keeping burly honest
joy leash but I was like Jesus this
guy's a dick and then he killed
broglie's animal friend thing he would
trained with what a dick he just trimmed
he just kindly removed this year yes
speaking of the extended freezer foster
I think one of my favorite characters in
this series for the earth bro least two
friends are they Qi Lian Li mo yeah I
liked them they were good fun they were
better than his crew in resurrection of
F they were proper fleshed out
characters which is very strange for a
dragon bull movie to have that kind of
auxilary nature about it it usually it's
just you're either an unnamed soldier or
you're an established side character who
gets almost nothing to do yeah they
weren't a saying and they got proper
character development it's a bit odd
yeah but in essence they're the most
important characters in the film because
they make the wish they remote away
they'll eventually teach Broly
not to be a raging monster that was so
that was that was very much Goku to just
show up like hey there's food I want to
fight you sometime Oh call me Kakarot
bye
I really really like that scene why he
just said but prolly call me Kakarot I
nearly cried oh it was it was a nice bit
of saying bonding
what if Brody just started freaking out
we just like Kakarot Kakarot I was half
expecting that because that's what I'm
so trained to thinking you know probably
Kakarot bad compassion I'm open old
broad he comes out of nowhere if you
thought the movie was over no this is
the second act before I was new
I'm honestly so annoyed that they're
adding the new Broly to Dragon Ball
fighters because like I love him but why
the hell did they add the old one then I
don't need to his release maybe the
others do no I want the new bro lino old
Broly I wouldn't buy you Broly to be at
it probably made yes
only by Rollie cheese
then you could have an entire team of
brutally you Brolio only by a really
really long talk but by Abril is
definitely the best movie of all Salem
let me know installing him also Trunks
and Goten still haven't grown up at all
and still exactly the same as they were
in Siebel I know which is hilarious
considering the fact that Goku literally
went from their age to what like a
full-grown adult at the end of Dragon
Ball
it's odd what that doing with us - I
mean they're never going to grow are
they because this is supposed to take us
to the end of Dragon Ball Z isn't it
yeah we've seen like an old eternal
flashback at the coin timeline I think
doesn't match up with the end of the
anymore applied any have it like a few
enough abet yeah
Goku wanted to fight kids boo again but
as a normal person that now what's the
kids boo when you can fight a jira no
Broly yeah that's true boob was still
out there yeah I think we smash and who
was out there but he was a infant and
Goku was like ah he can't fly maybe
small Nerys more main was like
motivation for finding a rubies to train
him so he doesn't turn out evil but but
isn't it like and like the most pure
hearted person or something yeah he is
really pure he was like supposed to be
the complete opposite of Kid Buu except
strong just like Kid Buu but this isn't
about Kid Buu this is about Broly and we
all laughed
noob Rolly I do like noob early I
actually like new Gogeta too like I
didn't really like his attitude and
Fusion reborn but in this one I really
liked it yeah to be honest there's no
character in the movie I don't like like
I like all of them they made everyone
like feel like they're just two people
from Dragon Ball and nothing different
they gave every character they chose to
focus on the time they needed to
actually be a character and even Pecola
was peak on the roof is annoyed faces so
I was happy I know piccolo was just
standing on his rock like what the hell
are these goddamn monkeys doing now Goku
are you gonna win this you need any help
like what did he think he was going to
do at that point
anyways what he looks like oh good you
guys think you can win this like no
pickle oh okay well I'll just stay here
anyways I'll come over there and stretch
my arms forgot I could do that I think
um I know this is a little off topic but
Piccolo's character evolution has been
great he's gone from this guy that
wanted to destroy the world to this guru
- Goku and Gohan and you're just like
this wise 28-year old New Mexican see
you in the 28 yeah he is
I'm older than piccolo wait a minute
does this mean that people who killed
himself at like 30-something years old
that's that know what else is sad is the
fact that denday has not grown
whatsoever but piccolo was like what
full-grown by the time he was three four
or five not even like two years old I
mean come on
some namekians grow faster than others
guys let's not judge Dan they just
doesn't grow at all none of us he uses
the Dragon Balls
I bet then they secretly I'll be no no
they were all wiped out by super comic
guru named dangerously into the bridge
we've spent a lot of time talking about
what was so great about Broly do any of
you have any criticisms of the film I've
got one I think I know what it is for go
ahead
there was no god damn Master Roshi yeah
I think that helps the film to be honest
although why did he not just show up and
you know trap Broly in the muff over its
muffle button it always annoyed are they
like reintroduced that concept during
the Goku black arc and then just failed
completely I was like why the hell did
you even bring it back if you're we just
closed a hell just on that fairly inert
Dragon Ball Z is kind of well Dragon
Ball in general is always kind of being
about failure like just take the Buu
walk for instance all the crap that
happens there like místico Han all the
fusion they all fail one after another
yeah but like when me and you talked
about that I think we came to that you
you helped me understand that was kind
of like the desperation arc like they
had every single tool at their disposal
at that time and nothing they hit him
with would work that's what makes me
appreciate that our
cuz literally they tried everything they
exhausted every single resource and
nothing worked except a champ except for
the champ
doctor it's just a sort of thing I've
come to expect they're like when a
villain approaches there's going to be a
lot of ideas floating around and almost
none of them are going to work yeah to
be honest with you I know this is off
topic but as much as I like Goku black
the whole arc and it's like ridiculous
it was stupid like I don't know
it's a low point in super for me a very
low point it was just such a bad ending
to such a great arc well I think it had
potential but I think one of the main
problems was they had a different writer
for every other episode so it was like
concepts they were gonna run with get
dropped and you know and that's how you
end up with faces in this guy yeah or
like Super Saiyan trunks swords yeah not
as bad as faces in this guy huh
the birth Rolly I just like the talking
boats you find talking I'm disappointed
or happy that he didn't mention careful
beliefe yeah it was kind of like hail
yeah okay yeah colorful the woman burly
that's Kol see Liam chaos a woman bro a
cliff loser super same one too many
stupid super characters weird Hama I'm a
new fan fiction and I'll go with Kaylin
ProLiant how many other with Chilean
Broly probably more the second the only
thing I wish that there was more of in
this movie was I kind of wish we get to
see Vegeta go back to his planet and
everything and how that went
you know with him serving Frieza and
everything but we got more than I
expected in the first place so I guess
it's rude of me to ask for more
oh you can always ask for more joy I
have a criticism that I'm not sure any
of you will understand but um when the
fighting began
broglie's shouting got very tedious yeah
for me because there was a lot of it and
in Japanese it was quite I don't know
how to explain it but it happened a lot
then over and over again it was like
they had a clash then burly would yell
and they'd have a bit more of a question
burly would yell again then there's
another clash and more yelling and the
other thing and yelling in yelling yes I
was justified from paratus die but he's
allowed to yell then yes but there was
lots of yelling before and after that
some of the point aside I think when you
kept realizing that the other Saiyans
had levels he could not surpass like I
could see him getting pissed off and
getting you know but there was a lot of
yelling it was like reminding me of the
old movie and I was like no no no don't
do this if he starts yelling Kakarot I'm
[ __ ] out it was just difficult on the
ears for me maybe I was sitting
particularly close to a speaker or
something and it was specifically when
beroldy was yelling not anyone else it's
funny because I looked when I was
watching the movie again yesterday I
realized that they played all right
when Vegeta first turns red and starts
fighting Broly there's like this fast
scene and Vegeta lands a punch then they
play it again after Broly powers up and
it's the exact same scene except Broly
hits him instead of a cheetah hitting
him and I was like wait a minute like I
rewatched I was like that was just the
same exact scene except Broly hate him
this time in shrieking and it didn't
notice that well like I said I was
getting all those Vegeta shots yesterday
so I was like wait a minute that's the
same exact shot that hold on wait a
minute the animation collierville
overall was really good like it was even
be stunning even bits of a cgi like you
could tell us a GI but it was still
really good - it was really good looking
like yeah the only bit that I really had
pet peeves as there was the occasional
like freezer for ship that was like look
kind of bad in the sky but apart from
that it was all really good looking I
don't know there's one point where the
CGI was really bad when they did like
the final yeah I think it was like the
final flash in the Kamehameha at the
same time and it was just so out of
place looking yeah I think a lot of the
CG was a bit out of place like when the
ground started crumbling and everything
this is you were doing such a good job
in 2d why did we need it what did you
guys think about later psychedelic oh
yeah yeah when both of them took acid
and started fighting in that colorful
dimension yeah oh you know like they'd
see stylistically I've really liked it
it was beautiful to watch don't know how
or if it matters how it happened
yeah I'm still confused if they broke
into some kind of dimension if some
[ __ ] like hit does which has been
known to happen through yelling yes
absolutely
and we also know that there are pocket
dimensions because it has introduced us
to those things
yeah tweeted the first was saying it's
just kind of jarring because this is
always psychedelic zooms grain like it's
the sort of thing you just have to go
with really so they all hope I doing
this now just just sit back and enjoy
the action like you're 12 years old
again it'll be fun what if when they
were in that weird voice just came out
of nowhere and just like killed
Broly and then I was just over like what
the [ __ ] man okay sorry somebody paid me
to kill him
Gary paid me to kill him it's not a very
good thing to do yeah go could rather
pay people to kill him
yeah Goku would go down the other he's
on the route from hunter hunter that was
probably the funniest thing to me and
super for some reason when beerus and we
sound out that the first thing that I
had hit was Goku they were like you
[ __ ] idiot so we just thing cuz it's
like in the series they were like oh who
did it and then it just like couple
episodes I was like oh of course you
just hide himself
does anyone else really dislike Goku
after super haha yeah are you talking
about I totally wouldn't endanger the
whole universe hmm it's bit of an odd
odd huh Vegeta feels to me much more
like a hero than Goku is yeah that's
what I was just saying at the very big
okay you could
I mean the very beginning of the movie
you can tell Vegeta is like sick of his
[ __ ] like you idiot you let him go again
first ball burn vajayjay look at him
like what are you doing Oh relax Vegeta
it'll be fine best buddy twelve
genocides later it will be fine don't
worry Vegeta we have the Dragon Balls
wait no we don't well no we don't cause
Bulma just made a wish again we're back
here again that was another thing I
don't know if you guys noticed but they
went back to the hole one wish format
which was kind of funny I did notice
that I mean if we reckoning stuff I
guess why not cuz the whole to wish
thing is it's being a bit clunky I think
in the past well the whole to wish thing
because they forgot that they made rules
they forgot that they got rid of
immortality but yet it's super we still
have people like I want to be immortal
we're like whoa our Dragon Balls don't
do that anymore yeah I think like I
heard some like people talking about how
there might have been actually two
wishes save Broly and then send him back
to vampire that makes sense but they do
say that you only get one wish though in
the film am i tripping big green out
like a fight against general something
like that no we thought gee I don't like
that's GT and then pick a little killed
gen around before that even happened
yes that's confusing likewise in general
if I had to pick one but afraid of B
words because it's Dragon well but I
don't think they ever planned on people
becoming as powerful as they are now
King Piccolo we trying to tell me this
wasn't planned Akira Toriyama planned
all of this out he knew he was going to
keep messing things up and keep fixing
them and that Bardock could see the
future and then not see the future and
Broly would be stabbed with a dagger and
thrown in a hole then don't be stuck
with the dagger just be sent somewhere
so going forward with the super universe
really is a pretty big deal one yes
he's one of those characters who we
can't just go how that was a fun film
we'll ignore that and move on to the
next thing he's another one of those
problematic characters now that needs to
be interest because he's so incredibly
powerful I have a feeling and I could be
wrong but I think he might eventually
attract the attention of beerus hmm
yeah because like the super manga is
going at the moment so i wonder if he'll
be involved in the massage if the anime
comes back the enemy at all and only
name-dropped him in that hmm
I've always liked the film came out I
had a theory that Broly was going to be
the Super Saiyan God that beerus was
dreaming about so I don't know I just
feel like this he's gonna become
interested in him at some point or at
least even the fact that we swiss
dodging his attacks and like playing
around with him kind of showed me that
he had some kind of interest in him
yeah this was having a good old time
which is great you know who doesn't like
like wheeze I like wheeze and like
beerus they wish that we could finally
get to a point where they had something
to do there yeah I thought that's how
super was gonna end to be honest with
you as beerus was finally gonna have to
fight goku again i mean that's how it
will end
that's how its set up yeah will the girl
pass the end of the day or will just
ended a very no it's does even happen
anymore
yeah like group said the timeline is
kind of screwed up now I don't even
think it could transition into Z you
know I feel like it still could they
still find ways to - well yeah they did
finally like give us a concrete history
instead of like the fragmented saying
story we had was sort of forming a new
backer background story leading up to
the end of the like I said it makes it
kind of makes me worried a reboot if the
entire series like going forward from
there
I miss animation I've wanted that for a
while to be honest with you like
something that starts backward
Dragonball starts or we already have a
general idea that he's an alien and
everything like that because like I said
man they made everything up that's they
went along piccolo was a demon Goku is
just a monkey boy and then Z happened
and everybody was an alien and Frieza
was like the most
or in character in the universe
technically yep
until cell and majin buu and beerus and
whis and all the other universes well I
mean yeah but I mean to the overall
story he's the one that blew up the
planet had Goku Center you know what I
mean he's the one that kind of
kick-started the whole story if you
think about it without Frieza there is
no Dragon Ball exactly so it's weird
that he was introduced so much later but
like I said they just made him up later
so it wasn't like he was always in the
back of a carrot or a I'm his mind like
yes I have this evil space tyrant I
can't wait to introduce him it was just
like let's make an evil space tyrant
yeah it was like my first series was
about magic next one aliens yes exactly
to be honest with you he only planned
out initially to the point where pilaf
gets his first wish and they were gonna
end there and why I defended them yeah
but I guess people were interested and
he kept going so which is what happened
forever and it hasn't stopped to this
day it's tough for what legend I have is
what happened to Vegeta Super Saiyan
blue Beyond it'll probably wear ultra
instinct is I don't think he can control
it properly yeah I'm on the end under
the impression he can't control it
properly but at the same time that goes
against most of what everything Z taught
us like the fact that after Goku
transformed into a Super Saiyan for the
first time it was almost second nature
to him the best way to enjoy these
things is simply to not question them
yeah but that's what I do just like you
question one piece I correct and I think
oh it is a bit more consistent than
Toriyama just a bit oh he's definitely
more consistent he had a plan at least
Akira Toriyama was just like balls
wishes monkeys let's go
I'm just so happy that loopy a lot ultra
instinct I know right yes which is
master Shaggy got them it's top of
shaking me you'll date this video if you
put means that don't put memes in it
this video is already dated because
we're talking about a movie that came
out three days ago in a week it not be
new anymore I mean I think he's gonna
age well except for the 3d stuff I agree
with you I need to start my mission of
making everybody watch it you should
yeah this is one of the very few like
anime movies that I would recommend to
my greater circle of friends well I made
Hoffman watch the abridged Broly movie
first to get ready for this one so it's
a good solid background actually it
really is but yeah overall I had no real
serious complaints it was by far my
favorite movie so far
I completely agree except I have one
more complaint and it has to do with one
of the soundtracks while they were
fighting which is very distracting when
they kept going oh my god or is it Broly
g-tech oh yeah GoPro yeah yeah I know
cheetah yeah it really takes you out of
it especially the first time you hear it
cuz I was like is that but is someone
saying that he's that dialogue freezer
is that you you know yeah I know it
seems that they have trouble coming up
with like epic songs for the cat just
yeah we need an epic song with lyrics
names go change huh coach a tough cookie
to Brody
Rolly did start throwing another names
are like Ken Amba cell 17 by you and
Broly when I'm walking for the second
time I was my like wrestling friend and
he actually said it made him remind him
of like wrestling it did have been that
long really pumping you up which is good
it's kind of first you like what what is
this but then I
okay
after you get used to it it's alright it
was just very in dish elite jarring
actually I do have one complaint that
the final attack from Gogeta was a copy
ha me hmm was just a comment and in wish
it was a final coming on me ha or
something I'd the two attacks
I didn't hear final them say before
maybe they I guess it was just coming
she's just finished the most powerful
attack known to man big idea feet I mean
it make sense but I know it it's just
when I was watching it again I kind of
thought it was funny the fact that
basically win but Vegeta was fighting
burly by himself Vegeta like got knocked
down and was like alright I'll take a
break but then Goku like got the literal
[ __ ] beat out of him and Vegeta was just
there forever like alright I guess I'll
just step in again that seems hard to
watch because it's just him getting
beaten up and screaming it's like oh god
stop make it stop yeah I know that's the
point where I was like wait what
happened to Vegeta and then I like when
I watched it again I was like oh you
never even got knocked out he kind of
just like took a knee and then Goku was
like I'll take care of this best buddy
and Vegeta was like yeah it was a tag
out yeah so like you think that visual
later just standing with Balmer waist on
like some ice watching it happen Vegeta
is extremely patient actually that's a
lie in the resurrection F he started
fighting like his turn but one of the
big things that I liked about this movie
that resurrection of F didn't have was
the fact that I never felt like there
was any threat in resurrection of F if
you know what I mean like I just felt
like Goku and Frieza were on the same
level and we had Vegeta there who had
not even done anything yet and we knew
he was pretty much just as strong as
Goku was but this movie we actually felt
like oh [ __ ] what are they gonna do yeah
I mean they kind of had an inkling of
what they were gonna do cuz they're just
a plethora of options available Fusion
for example but yeah our direction of F
didn't kind of couldn't feel like
anything especially in comparison to
this movie it's just yeah a bit flat
yeah
it looks nice but really there was no
like I said no threat or anything it was
just Frieza coming back and then getting
the [ __ ] beat out of him and then Vegeta
almost killing him
and getting his kill stolen and then
time travel convenient could be new time
travel but yeah it was probably my
favorite after battle of the gods
you ranked battle of gods above this no
no no right underneath it
oh just lost a lot of respect you the
first four spots go to the new bro Lee
movie and the fifth spot goes to battle
of the gods for me this movie episode of
bad dog bio Broly yeah those are my top
three the bottom special is fantastic
was it not the original was the sequel
no no he goes back in time and fights
what is it Lord chill Lord
yeah I think both of the fire - ones
were kind of half-assed like the whole I
can see the future thing was just like
what the man's got 20/20 vision thanks
dad oh my Bardock seemingly lost his
power to see into the future like how
like he actually deductively came up
with oh wait fleece is probably gonna
kill us all on his own
you know though I can see the future
yeah he used his brain which is
fantastic someone's playing their combat
oh sorry I'm so sorry
I didn't know that this was on the
bamboo fun like cheese we take the time
to invite you to this wonderful
discussion and what do you do I'd like a
Cheeto blue vegeta red Gogeta blue
I like to admit enough items to be Jeeto
Master Roshi yeah here at muffled by
both of them I mean in the super manga
he technically told out you had a
daughter instinct or whist having not
read the super manga I'm very unfamiliar
with that idea the super manga actually
is beyond the tournament of power so at
the moment so have you read the manga or
not thank you okay that no no anybody
other than Liam I have I have yeah so
you're all at the news chapter right so
I am yeah we're not gonna be good
wait a minute let's go make fun of Liam
for a second because he's actually not
caught up this time no no no this is an
eye area of specialty well sort of I do
why don't you read it I do but you will
never know because watching Dragon Ball
super for me is very much a nostalgic
experience these are the characters I
like and their voices are cool in here
Krillin is luffy reading the manga is
less of an experience for me especially
if it's of a similar quality of story
but you will never get to see ultra
instinct Roshi we don't need this that's
what you'll never get to see I need it I
think I'm okay with that
the worst part is the fact that when you
look at users of ultra instinct Master
Roshi is now on the list and I'm like Oh
for [ __ ] sake is this this is an
actual thing he went okay yeah well
technically
I wasn't actually girl tree instinct but
it looks like yeah when uses he got the
movement yeah they've categorized his
abuses
beerus master roshi Goku and then beerus
then goku he's a buffoon Master Roshi
the guy who refuses to learn how to fly
because he thinks that the crane school
created it he can't use the limbus as
well cuz he's pure of heart I'm sure
that uh you know the crane school also
taught Frieza how to fly definite very
popular school all right so we've been
going on for probably long enough so
we're gonna go around the table and give
some final thoughts beginning with mr.
droid I was very happy with the movie I
liked the new fleshed out backstory and
I thought the fighting was amazing I
give this movie a 9.5 what would give it
the extra point five out of curiosity I
took off some points for the weird CGI
stuff yep fair enough
all right Groot your final thoughts
honestly favourite Dragon Ball movie yet
give a solid 9 out of 10 mm slightly
less enjoyed controversial cheese what
about you yes same asteroid but I would
give it 9 instead of 9.5 cause same with
you I didn't lie as I didn't enjoyed
music at the end the good you talita
internally yeah there was no beliefs huh
so really you should be giving it like a
three out of 10 because spire Broly
makes up so many points yes okay 3 out
of 10 good huh mejia final thoughts
please yes
similar to grow to probably best Dragon
Ball movie I've ever seen it's great
everything bad was great
overall I'd give it a nine point nine
holy [ __ ] and that point one is
obviously because of missing Russia has
no Master Roshi yeah damn it's a pretty
high rating
the busy Roshi's only works out to you I
should know that's true I can't one
other ten point one out of ten point one
ahead of ten nine point now in this
master roshi best Dragon Ball movie ever
point one out of ten too much water are
you saying too much as for me by far the
best Dragon Ball movie I've ever seen in
my life it was a really good experience
watching it in a cinema with people and
wonderful sound and I hope they continue
to make more of this stuff in the future
agreed I'm glad you liked it because I
told you like the day before I was like
it's amazing you'll love it it's awesome
and you're like well if it fails to meet
my expectations then and I was like oh
[ __ ] yeah then I said I would get to
blame here because hyping stuff up is
it's a serious thing you shouldn't do it
too much but yeah it was well worth it
in this case just say it's good or not
it deserves the hot
I am the hype yeah alright well thank
you guys very very much I've got no idea
when this video is going to be up but
she is for joining me on this discussion
no problem any time